denkt jetzt nicht jeder junge macht das
jeden abend so und jedoch erlaubnis
bekommen bei neuen video und zu habe ich
mir für heute gedacht also wir jungs wir
sind zwar zu einem großen teil gestört
aber eigentlich sind wir schon normale
menschen und deshalb gehen wir auch
jeden abend ganz normal schlafen was
schon 150
da muss ja immer flussbett hier hüpfen
aber auch in echt anstrengender tag
heute morgen ist ja schule management so
sieht das irgendwie nicht aus ihr wisst
wahrscheinlich aufgrund des titels schon
worauf ich hinauswill es geht dort
einfach so um die dinge die wir jungs so
halt so einem großen teil wirklich vom
einschlafen machen es ist nicht immer so
einfach wie man denkt leute so geht es
nicht ich will auch gar nicht lange und
fahren direkt an wenn es euch gefällt
wenn ihr auch mal das gleiche mit
mädchen wollten schreibt in die
kommentare was mädchen vor dem 1 schafft
man kann ich ja nicht wissen dann lassen
doch noch und auch wenn ihr wollt euch
gefällt und livescores ja bevor man ins
bett geht muss man sich erst mal seinen
schlafanzug anziehen ich oder wie man
sich das ist ja auch scheißegal auf
jeden fall gehe ich jetzt nicht so
schlafen deswegen zieht man sich erst
mal um und das sieht bei den meisten
jungen dann schon so aus und nicht so
ganz normal
wenn ich mir schon wieder breiter
geworden geld ja wenn das jetzt nur bei
mir so ist dann habe ich ein kleines
problem jetzt aber ich glaube das ist
eigentlich schon bei fast allen so ihr
macht natürlich direkt weiter und zwar
legt sich dann jeder jungen ganz normal
in sein bett oder auf dem boden oder vor
die haustür oder auf die straße oder
unter den kleinen mann legt sich dann
natürlich in sein bett und greift
meistens noch zum handy so mache ich das
zumindest und da macht man dann
folgendes ab und zu mal ganz selten
endlich kann ich schlafen moment mal was
prozent noch gar nicht sein
nee vorm schlafengehen kam eine runde
noch geil alter zehn neue followern heiß
war dies geilmann völlig direkt mal
zurück geil geil ich hätte gern in t
shirt wie ich an gossip ein alter mann
ja wenn das wort spaß und immer das
gefühl wenn man dann wirklich einer hat
die auf zurück folgt aber irgendwie
kommt das selten vor
leute ich bin ganz ehrlich ich kann
jetzt hier auch irgendeinen scheiß
erzählen aber so ist das wirklich das
ist einfach so ja und dann kommen wir
jetzt auch schon zusammen punkt der ist
halt wirklich so vielleicht nicht
unbedingt nur bei jungs so aber
irgendwie auch schon also weiß ich
manchmal einfach so das verlangen oder
es fehlt einfach noch so plötzlich ein
folgendes zu tun weiß gar nicht wie ich
das jetzt sagen soll
ich mach doch mal meine hausaufgaben
bekomme ich viel lösung man es kann doch
nicht sein jetzt noch mein stiftung.de
stück kaputtgegangen
jaja leute ich glaube ihr habt also was
falsches gedacht natürlich das kann auch
vorkommen allerdings denkt jetzt nicht
jeder yoga macht das jeden abend so okay
doch und wenn man das dann als junge in
der ganz normalen schulzeit so gegen 1
uhr geschafft hat kann man dann ganz
normal schlafen gehen um dann um halb
acht wieder aufzustehen oder viertel
vorab man hat ja macht schule und hat
dann halt auch seine sechs stunden
schlaf so sieht es halt bei den meisten
jungs aus ist eigentlich so wenn es
nicht so aussieht bei euch jungen sowie
ein junge sagt schon könnt ihr mir das
gerne sagen aber ich weiß ganz genau
bescheid ihr schlingel ja welche das
war's mit diesem video wenn es euch
gefallen dann könnt ihr gerne daumen
nach oben lassen würde mich sehr freuen
schreibt auch in die kommentare was ihr
als mädchen macht bevor er schlafen geht
ins tram strip war es eingeblendet
wir sehen uns am nächsten dienstag
wieder hier oben links geht heute mit
einem letzten check das auf jeden fall
mal ab und ja ich wünsche euch noch
einen traumhaften sonntag verdrängt